[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للخطاب الاخير قلت لك يوم الخميس
13 كلمني الرئيس ااه حتى انزل الى جانبه
للمكتب قال ان هنالك كلمه يريد ان يلقيها
ااا
في الوضع الذي كان سائدا ان ذلك في البلاد
ولما ااه
تحولت
الى مكتب الرئيس
وجدت ان هنالك مشروع
فيما بعد علمت ان المشروع
اعده حكيم القروي وهو
اتصالي واطار تونسي يعيش في الخارج فرنسا
على ما اظن
وقال للرئيس انا ذاكر ومش هنتكلم بالدارجه
اللغه بتاع الشاعر بالعاميه
والخيار والكتابه بالعاميه بتحل جاء وكان
سياحه
اتصاليه طبعا
انا لست متعود بالكتابه
بالعاميه يعني لم اكتب مسرحيه
رايت ان ذلك ممكن
[موسيقى]
هل استطاع الرئيس ان يجذب الناس اليها ان
يتعاطف او على الاقل شريحه قليله ولو
قليله ان تتعاطف معهم من خلال هذه
الخطابات امانا لم تؤتي اكلها تماما
النتيجه بينت انها لم تاتي اكلها يعني
مقاطع
وهكذا الرئيس
[موسيقى]
ان يقوم به وان يصلح حاله التي تتحدث عنها
كان ينوي ان يقوم بها فلم يتاخر بذلك
كثيرا
ولكن السباق اصبح معك السباق همم زمن
السياسي
لان في ال 24 ساعه الاخيره اصبح سباق من
نوع جديد لم نعرفه سابقا وهو سباق
اتصال همم
القنوات الاجنبيه الى اخره
اعلامي وبدا التشويه والشيطان بدات منذ
البدايه
[موسيقى]